[Music]
hey
y'all it's what the hell day is it
sunday
[Laughter]
yes hopefully uh you guys can hear us
okay because now i'm paranoid every
single time
because of the stupid settings on this
[ __ ]
um also i hope everyone's not confused
because of the time change
uh it's sprang forward last night i
don't know
most of you i only knew because my
computer
like uh gave me a little notification
so i was kind of prepared for it but i
don't know if you guys were so
if if we're at some weird time because
of that that's why
uh looks good and sounds good says louie
uh yeah louie i'm glad you're here
because
uh you're the one that sent us this
movie yeah it's a good movie
i really really like this a lot and you
know what i'm this is
how much of a dummy i am this came out
back in 2017
and i didn't realize but this is the
same writer director that did
sicario and also heller high water
it's almost kind of like a that you know
they're not the same story obviously but
they're kind of like a loose trilogy
i think it's called the frontier trilogy
so this is like the third one
uh taylor sheridan is the guy's name so
he wrote and directed sicario
and this one as well so as i said this
came back uh
out in 2017 and i hadn't heard of this
one which is crazy because
it's really really good and i'm
but in a way i'm kind of glad that i
didn't that i hadn't heard about it
because
i think it's kind of better going into
it not really knowing what's going to
happen
yeah it's kind of like a police
procedural kind of
movie which ends up being kind of like
an action
type movie in in in the latter half it's
based on
on a real case i think well from what i
could determine i don't know if it's
based on a specific case or
or if it's based on an amalgam of cases
because it does really seem like um
it kind of goes a lot into
how murders uh and crimes are not really
uh solved all that well like when they
happen on
uh native american reservations yeah
outside u.s jurisdiction so
so they have to have the feds come in
and then like you know it's just kind of
this [ __ ] so i think that
the story like i said it's sort of like
it's a murder mystery
but then it kind of goes into sort of
like an action movie toward the end
kind of in the sense that there's like a
lot of gunfights and whatnot yeah
another thing i liked about it is it
kind of goes uh kind of
kind of it kind of lets people who don't
really know much about the united states
or
people maybe up in the northeast they
don't realize
how remote some of these areas are
yeah and and how you could be in a
certain place where
you can't get any police service they
might be hours away
the police back up is impossible in
other words like if the police need
that need help help for them is like
[ __ ] hours and hours away
so in a way this is kind of happening
in an environment that's a lot like the
old west or
on the in the frontiers it's a lot like
that
yeah i mean this a lot of america's
still like that
i mean growing up in mississippi almost
all of mississippi was like that outside
of a damn town
you know what i mean yeah heidelberg
mississippi had two cops one for the day
one for the night
yeah everybody took care of themselves
but everybody knew each other
yeah you know i mean this is actually
based on
um or it's set in a real as far as i
know is a real place the wind river
indian reservation which is in wyoming
and it's kind of set
in um now didn't they say that it was
like
i don't remember if they said it was
summertime or august or something like
that but still everyone's just like for
yeah it's sort of like frozen and
covered because it's like way
[ __ ] up so like i said everywhere they
went you had to go
on you know like a [ __ ] ski thing or
what what the [ __ ] do you call those
things know the snow
cat the like snowmobile thing yeah some
of this and uh they had to kind of go
through there
so uh the story behind this though is
that
this is really interesting because both
jeremy renner and elizabeth olsen
are in this who are both uh avengers
actually
it was it's hawkeye and scarlet witch
this is like a totally totally different
movie than that
so i guess jeremy renner he plays um
he's like a fish and wildlife
guy so his job is actually to track
animals that are killing people's
livestock so at the beginning there's
like all these people's uh
you know livestock or sheep or whatever
get killed and they determine that
there's like a mama lion
and her two cubs and that she's the one
killing all of them
so he's kind of like looking for her so
he can shoot the lion and while he's out
doing that
he finds a dead teenage girl
and the odd thing about it is that she's
kind of frozen out there
and she's barefoot but she's like six
miles from the nearest thing and they
were just like how the [ __ ] did she get
this far
barefoot and you know only died like
right here
you know what i mean and uh so then
you're trying to figure out they can't
figure out like the cause of death and
then it turns out that
when they take her to the coroner that
they can tell that she has been
raped uh multiple times but
he's like i can't put homicide on the
death certificate
because the technicality because like
technically she didn't die from that
she died from running in [ __ ]
freezing cold temperatures and the
you know the alveoli or whatever in her
lungs like essentially exploded and she
drowned in her own blood
so it's like so that was the cause of
death and he's like i know that her
being out there running and
her getting raped and [ __ ] like that
contributed to her death but i can't put
homicide on the death certificate
because
technically she didn't die from that
technically she you know died
because of the cold so so what happens
with that is they send
one lone fbi agent out there to check
out what the [ __ ] is going on
and if he doesn't put homicide on the
death certificate then they can't get
any more backup so basically the fbi
agent who's played by elizabeth olsen
she has to get the fish and wildlife guy
you know to help her because there's a
lot of like tracking involved like where
you know where the girl came from you
know why you know and tracking like
other people's
snowmobiles and [ __ ] like that to try
and figure out who did this to her who
was chasing her
so they have to kind of work together
with the one cop
in town and like figure out what
happened to this poor girl
and it's just i mean the way like the
cinematography is gorgeous i love the
way that they
kind of everything is just white and
it's just this
like you said you really really get a
sense of how remote this place is
and how you're really kind of [ __ ] and
you're on your own like when something
like this happens
and it's just this really sad like
everybody that lives on this reservation
is just kind of like
used to it there's kind of like yeah
well nothing's gonna happen yeah it's
funny
feds send this girl to investigate and
when she shows up to investigate she
didn't have a [ __ ] damn jacket
yeah well because they sent her from
vegas to vegas yeah just like yeah go
check that out
it's summer time so they figured oh well
you know they didn't take an account
that it's [ __ ] frozen up there
right and these are all arapaho indians
i think i think they were yeah
because i think that's what the one that
wasn't totally clear but i think well i
think they said when the the victim's
dad was talking
i think that said because i always put
the closed captioning on because i'm
deaf but uh so that's what language he
was speaking
yeah i like the fact that they they
mention a lot of stuff about
reservation life you know what i mean
like the cop told the one guys oh you
could have had anything you could have
gone to the army
when i was in the army you know served a
lot of uh native american guys that came
from these reservations
and it's across the board you know uh
you know they
some have real nice houses some of them
are real rich because
the reservation is now damn casino you
know
and then some of them just don't have
anything they're just looking
burned out trailers and [ __ ] you know
uh but in general there's kind of a
brain
drain going on in a lot of those uh
reservations anybody who's you know
got potential leaves they go to the army
they ended up they end up in service
actually federal service of some sort
and uh so you me they're cool dudes you
know
kind of the same with the islands too a
lot of micronesians a lot of wines and
stuff
some owens and they kind of come from
some similar situation you know trying
to get off the island
they never go back i keep in contact
with them
dasco he's still here he didn't go back
he didn't go back to the islands
but uh yeah it's just i i like i like
how they were just kind of true to the
true to the
to true to the situation yeah it's
really this place is kind of out in the
middle of nowhere it's like the only
other
like the only white people there are you
know people that kind of married in
yeah jeremy renner's character who
actually was married to a native uh to
an indigenous woman but then they got
divorced they have a son together
so he still lives there because he works
for fish and wildlife but other than
that it's just kind of like temporary
workers because i guess there was like
what was it an oil refinery or some kind
of or oil drilling or something like
that
so there was kind of like a camp where
they had like all these trailers there
were some white dudes like working out
there
um but other than that it's just kind of
like this really really small
and like you said a lot of the people
had left and the ones that were kind of
remaining there they felt like
you know this is out in the middle of
nowhere there are no opportunities for
them and stuff like that so all they do
is kind of
um you know the the brother of the girl
that gets murdered
is just kind of like a drug addict you
know him and his friends just sit in
this [ __ ] burned out trailer and just
do drugs all the time yeah because they
don't have anything else to do
the rest of them were farmers you know
livestock farmers
yeah they were doing good you know what
i mean they had nice houses and stuff
it's just
that life isn't for everybody and you
need to get amount of money to start as
a farmer too you know that money just
didn't come out of the ground
so uh but yeah it was kind of cool
a lot of reservations nowadays are damn
casinos
well yeah they got a casino on a man
they make a [ __ ] ton of money
yeah i think like here we have uh
several reservations out in
uh on the west coast of florida and they
have like a lot of seminole reservations
and stuff and they all have casinos
they do pretty well i think yeah but um
yeah but this one like i said it's kind
of out in the middle of nowhere
so you have to do livestock you can't
really grow anything because it's
[ __ ] fertile all the time it's too
cold
um but i mean just the the acting in
this was really really good was you know
what my favorite
one of my favorite scenes in this was
when
um you know when they go to basically
tell
uh the dad of the victim that that she's
dead
and the fbi agent you know elizabeth
olsen's character she kind of gets off
on the wrong foot because she's like
well why
why didn't you know where because at
that point they thought that her
boyfriend had killed her
or whatever because she was like dating
a white dude and um
so she was like well didn't you know the
boyfriend's name or didn't you know
where she was and they were like
you know she's 18. it's like she just
she does what she wants to do and it's
like why
like why are you so judgy and [ __ ] like
that so he was like real stoic and
everything like that but once she had
left
like he went outside with the fish and
wildlife guy and just
you could hear him just like crying and
like
you know just this agonizing kind of
whale out there like for some stuff like
that but it was like a really really
good
like effective scene i didn't realize i
haven't seen jeremy renner in a lot of
stuff
other than like i said the avengers
movies um
but he's like really really good in this
you know what i mean he's like a really
really good actor
it's funny that it's just funny there's
two avengers in this i don't know why i
thought that was so funny because it's
like a totally different kind of movie
than that
jess says she's got to get her 13
o'clock top man and said it looked good
i had to drop a super chat and i know
you're in australia
but what's the shipping to australia you
know um i don't know it's usually not
that different from uk strangely
okay um because i think i have shipped
some stuff to
australia before and it wasn't horribly
expensive 20
super chat i'll send you one one of your
choice
even have uh we even have girls cut tees
don't we
yeah you have any titty shirts uh i
don't know i have to look at my
looking at my back the thing about it is
that i don't the sad thing is i don't
think we have
this design like the friday the 13th one
i don't think we have this screen
anymore i don't have a screen anymore i
mean i could shoot another one
um if we had to because i still have the
design but
we'd have to shoot another yeah we'd
have to shoot another screen if you
wanted this particular one because we
threw it out like to do another one yeah
i needed the frame
yeah we need to do um for
xanada we need to do a pliskin shirt
yeah i gotta look through my stock and
see if i can burn yesterday
yeah i mean you know that's that's what
i figured it won't take that long to do
um you know and i think that i have that
address someplace well you got a large
in
stock um yeah sheila anne says taylor
sheridan acted on sons of anarchy see i
didn't even know that either
yeah yeah i think that's right i haven't
seen i got through a little bit of sons
of anarchy it started to get kind of
repetitive
yeah i think we watched like the first
season or most of the first season
and i liked it but i just didn't i guess
i don't know i got distracted by
something else or
a little too pg for me yeah the gangs
weren't quite ruthless enough they
weren't doing what
a lot of those gangs actually do you
know
yeah that's true so like i said it was a
long time ago that i watched it i did i
did like it but
like i liked the character we got done
with the first season of
first season of spartacus man that thing
was so [ __ ] good
yeah i forgot how good that was yeah i
don't know if i want to jump to season
three
where i left off or go back to season
two because season two actually is a
flashback it's a flashback
yeah because isn't batiatas in the
second one like it's kind of showing
yeah how he came yeah that was good too
because i really like that character
yeah more about the artists but in three
remember
what [ __ ] had it by the time he went to
[ __ ] two and then three i'd forgotten
what happened in one
and forgot that forgot the names of all
the damn characters and some of the cast
changed out yeah never that's oh yeah
that's right so that yeah that's the
thing it's like you really have to
it's probably better if you're gonna
watch it just like watch them all at
once because
you know what i mean um louis was asking
about wind river how realistic was the
standoff scene remember that one scene
where they were all like standing around
like [ __ ]
pointing at each other yeah actually i
think that might have been pretty
realistic because really those guys
didn't want to shoot each other
yeah if they wanted to shoot each other
just would have went down that was uh
they were trying to intimidate each
other
yeah a lot of people get killed so
yeah something like that could happen
yeah and like i said i don't know i
don't think from what i could determine
that this was based because it does say
based on actual events but i don't think
it's based on a very specific
crime as so much as it's based on
uh you know several different ones that
have happened in the area because i do
feel like
the the thing they said at the end about
native american women being like the
only
uh you know demographic group that they
don't
uh that you know they don't they don't
have that like as a category
for murder victims which i thought was
very strange
um i think we might have talked about a
little bit if we did
didn't we do a show about the highway of
tears like up in canada i think
we did that yeah or something like that
it's a similar kind of thing going on up
there
where um because of and particularly in
the us like the way that our
the laws are and concerning reservations
and whatnot
um i i feel like
women on those reservations they're more
vulnerable
they're a lot more vulnerable because
because of like [ __ ]
[ __ ] up [ __ ] with the law which which
like i said this movie shows it would be
like
it would be like committing a crime on
the on the boundary between two
countries
and yeah countries that don't kind of
like that and the two countries that
maybe don't cooperate real well
within each other because you know a lot
of those tribal police
really wouldn't have the budget to do a
whole bunch of investigation and
and or the equipment so they'd be like
yeah that girl disappeared we don't know
where she went
yeah it happens a lot and like i said
they illustrate that in this it's like
you know
the reservation has one cop yeah you
know what i mean and he's just like
he's got to do his daily duties and [ __ ]
you know yeah he's like i don't really
have any investigate for the next 10
years from what happened to some
chick yeah so so you know what i mean uh
whoever commits these kind of crimes
knows the situation
yeah like in this area i get away with
it and then maybe he might find out well
i get i'm getting away with it in this
area
because there's only one cop yeah and he
can he doesn't have the ability or the
time
or the money you know the the his the
budget to investigate this so as long as
i'm
hunting in this area i'm all right and
you know this has to do with the
treaties that happened
between these indian nations and the
united states long long time ago you
know so they want their independence
they don't want to give up their
independence so
there's going to be an anomaly in the
anomalies happening between the two
systems now the feds have the ability to
come in and do it
yeah which is illustrated in this movie
as well yeah but
but the thing is is there's a difference
between a missing person and a murder
if you never find the body then it might
it's just a missing person
and as as you saw in this movie that she
could that it couldn't be considered a
murder because she didn't die from
she didn't die from that she was raped
many times and obviously she was out in
the cold running in bare feet and died
because of that of the attack
but she technically didn't die of that
so they couldn't get all the feds
in there that they sent one person who
was like woefully unprepared for the
[ __ ] yeah
you know what i mean so it really does
kind of show and
and then like as it escalates and
escalates it's just really sad because
you know all these people get killed
it's like you know justice is served
but it's like it's just gonna happen
again
you know what i mean it's just kind of
like so it's almost kind of like a
what do they call that a pyrrhic victory
or something like that like at the end
i was just talking assad i was showing
him some videos
of like some shootings and stuff that
happened here in the united states
between the police and offenders
there's a real good youtube channel
called police activity that just shows
all the body cam
stuff uh real shootings you see
and you know you can see thousands and
thousands of these shootings
and it's definite patterns to them you
know you can tell who's gonna get shot
who's not a good shot
and him being from saudi arabia a
totally different system you know he's
all
horrified and i'm just like you don't
understand the situation these cops are
in
or you don't understand what it's like
in these gigantic systems
it's like a damn machine running and
you're just
they should if you attack the police
with a knife
those cops are never going to go
toe-to-toe with some dude and try to
wrestle a knife out of his hand
that dude gets hurt on a job it has to
police unions all kinds of insurance
if he gets stabbed it's always the
police's life is always paramount in
this [ __ ]
situation so they just shoot the dude
you know
and you're like oh that's pretty
hardcore well if you start giving new
orders to these cops well you got to get
in there and
wrestle this guy and take this knife
away and get all cut
cut up every day because this happens a
lot for these cops
then you're going to have cops quitting
the next thing you know there is no
police
and when there's no police it just
becomes basically
militias and you know lynch mobs and
anarchy what it was in the 1800s
because the united states didn't always
have police
you had local sheriffs in towns but they
weren't professional police force they
they were kind of like mall cops or a
lot of times a
sheriff in a town really was a retired
bank robber
or something like that you know i mean
the the
the same guys that were robbing trains
and robbing banks
also were the cops they just would move
to another town
and do another gig for a while matter of
fact some of the best lawmen in the old
west
were actually ex-criminals because once
you did your time
you had the ability to become a cop
afterwards they'd do a couple years in
prison and get out and become policemen
you know because they had paid for their
crime which i kind of liked that system
a little bit better that way you don't
have a criminal underclass
[ __ ] growing and growing and growing
you know
so everything has to do when you're
dealing with big systems like this
you're dealing with weird technicalities
and
weird legal disputes between
jurisdictions and really that's what
this movie's about
yeah and it's like i said it's really
and it's also like a really good like
really affecting
murder mystery like i said with a lot of
kind of brutal violence in it as well so
and like i said if you like sicario
it's a completely different story but um
but you would probably dig this one as
well and it's really weird because i
just hadn't heard about this one even
though it came out back in 2017
but you know so i really appreciate
louis sending it
uh as well oh and i almost forgot to
mention that
uh nick cave and warren ellis did the uh
score for those two
yeah which i didn't realize until i
looked it up
but i really liked the score of it and
then i was just kind of like oh that's
probably why
did he do the second sicario also
um i'm not really sure i'd have to look
it up they've him and warren ellis have
done like a [ __ ]
on of movie scores i think the second
sicario was a little bit better than the
first one
see you watch them without me okay yeah
they're good i haven't i like this so i
haven't got to see that
car the first zakaria was more about
like this yeah
yeah that but if you guys haven't seen
the sicario series want to see that
also that that's dealing very similar to
this movie but it has to do with the
mexican
border and the weird [ __ ] that's
happening between federal agencies and
the mexican agencies
federal american agencies and mexican
agencies and the cartels
and the weird grayness
between the two where you got
guys that are basically cartel assassins
that
work for the federal governments which
that's true
and like i said now now we have to see
um hell or high water which is the
second one
like before this one was after sicario
but it was like before this one
which is also a different story but like
a similar theme
i guess um but yeah so uh
yeah jones perkins said i saw this movie
when it first came out i was pleasantly
surprised
yeah it's just like i went back and
watched a lot of contemporary
uh youtubers that had reviewed it and
this it got like
you know really really good reviews
across the board and a lot of people
said that that they didn't really know
what to expect
but it ended up being like way way
better than they thought it was going to
be
but yeah it's like a really great like i
said murder mystery and then kind of
goes into
uh you know kind of like a no i don't
know if i'd call it an action movie but
it does kind of
have that kind of like a lot of violence
in it toward the end and i'm gonna say
i'm not gonna
really spoil the ending but uh that one
end scene with jeremy renner and that
one guy
were just like that that was really
really good it was like really really
satisfying
so i will say that but uh yeah so
uh thanks again louie for sending us
that because i don't think i would have
seen it otherwise
or i wouldn't have got around to it for
a really long time so you have anything
else you would like to add
saying i didn't say wrestling i said
tase him and i said [ __ ] that taser
ain't [ __ ] man [ __ ] i'll send you other
videos the guy got tased six times
just pulling the damn [ __ ] things out
once you're amped up
if you're amped up and [ __ ]
emotionally volatile
that [ __ ] taser is [ __ ]
also if you're hopped up on something or
you're not the muscle
they they know who they can tase and
they can't taste you're a [ __ ] they're
gonna tase you
if you're [ __ ] raged out on a bunch
of drugs or you're just crazy
they're not gonna tase you i just
i'll send you some [ __ ] [ __ ] side
you'll see what one dude [ __ ] ran
through about three tasers just pulled
him out and then
kept running at him with a knife in full
view they just lit him up just
cutting the shreds they're real tough
until them bullets start hitting them i
understand that they're insane they
don't think that they don't think that
they can be hurt
they kind of go kamikaze yeah that's
probably they're saying shoot me shoot
me [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay then you get shot dude why'd you
shoot me yeah well yeah then you throw a
bag
why did you do that yeah they don't make
it you told me to
yeah that makes sense they don't want to
go to jail
yeah yeah yeah louis says it's a
neo-western yes
that that is what they call this genre
where it's kind of like structured like
a western but it's not necessarily
yeah well that's i kind of said that
when i said it's like a frontier
it's like a frontier story yeah and like
i said i think they call this
sicario hell or high water and wind
river they call it the frontier trilogy
yeah another another thing that they did
was
uh towards the very end uh
the the uh the one wildlife guy he kind
of took care of justice the old school
way he that's the scene i was talking
about yeah he didn't kill him he let
nature he let the elements kill him
that's all it took and it was also like
poetic justice yeah
so i was kind of right i was just kind
of like yeah
i like the way i like your style you
know what i mean
but uh yeah so we will be back tomorrow
at 3 p.m eastern standard time like i
said some people i think obsessed was in
australia and was like
did you guys start earlier yeah it's
daylight savings time that's right
today so uh that's why i don't know like
who does
daylight savings time and who doesn't
around the world because i know some
countries do and some countries don't
[ __ ] with it
i wish we wouldn't [ __ ] with it it just
seems [ __ ] but you know what i mean
what are you going to do i can't from
another era it is it's just you had to
plant [ __ ] it's like [ __ ] we're not
farmers anymore we don't need that [ __ ]
they got robots farming it's just a pain
in the ass and it's like now my
now my sleep schedule's all messed up
and all this other kind of [ __ ] but
whatever
even the margaret workers are like man
stop building [ __ ] robots
yeah but uh so probably tomorrow we will
do
uh i think they they just added a new
shutter original called stay out of the
[ __ ] attic
and we watched that last night so we'll
probably talk about that a little bit
tomorrow uh louis says you guys in
florida have two time zones i don't
oh yeah i guess we do because i guess
the little bit of the panhandle
is in the other time zone what is this
what's the next one central
they're in party time yeah
but most of florida's eastern standard
time i think just a little bit of the
of the panhandle is uh in the next time
zone
but yeah uh seth says we do daylight
savings but in a month's time
i also hate it yeah it's just it seems
pointless in this day and age
seth is down there in australia man
that's where everything kills you
yeah even the ants kill you
they got them prehistoric ants that only
kind of act like ants
what are they called bullet ants oh i
know that there's some ants called that
but i don't know
what it is they're talking about cross
between an ant and a wasp they're in a
colony but they fight each other
[Music]
on civilization yeah you never heard
them
yeah i was like man that [ __ ] would only
exist in austin
badass primitive [ __ ]
australia seems fun i've always kind of
wanted to go there everything kills you
there
pretty much everything's [ __ ]
poisonous yeah yeah or venomous
or whatever or it'll just eat you yeah
oh poisonous and venomous are two
different oh see she wants to get
technical
in spock man i'm sorry i'm just saying
because it wants to be fantastic that's
two different things
all right so we will be back tomorrow
talking about
some more horror movies so uh thanks
everybody for
dropping by on this lazy sunday
we'll see you guys tomorrow bye